[موسيقى]
بتوقيت الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
بعد خلاف يوم ومناقشات شهور المعارضه
التركيه تتفق على كمال كلش دار اوغلو
مرشحا للرئاسه واردوغان يبدا الهجوم
اوكرانيا تتخلى عن خيار الانسحاب من باخمت
مؤقتا وروسيا تزيد الضغط
حوادث تصميم طالبات ايران تطلق فوضى
تصريحات رسميه المرشد يناقض الرئيس
واحتجاجات لاهالي المتضررين
جامعه افغانستان تعود للدراسه بلا نساء
العفو الدوليه تطالب الامم المتحده
بالتدخل والامم المتحده تطالب طالبان
[موسيقى]
اسعد مؤقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه اذا
مشاهدين التي نبداها من الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وهذه الاخبار العاجله من الضفه
الغربيه حيث افاد مراسل العربيه باصابه
عدد من الفلسطينيين في بلده حواره جنوب
نابلس جراء تجدد المواجهات بين
الفلسطينيين ومستوطنين اسرائيليين مراسلنا
اوضح ان المستوطنين الاسرائيليين هاجموا
منازل ومتاجر في حواره وهددوا السكان
واشار مراسل العربيه الى ان المستوطنين
الاسرائيليين حطموا عددا من السيارات في
حواره خلال مسيره راقصه وقبل قليل الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني اورد اول حصيله تتحدث عن
اصابه سته فلسطينيين اذا بجروح جراء هذه
الاعتداءات من المستوطنين الاسرائيليين
على حواره على العموم معنى الان مراسلنا
خالد القاسم مباشره من رام الله خالد ما
الذي جرى ويجري في حوار
يعني الذي جرى بان عائله مكونه من خمسه
افراد كانت تتسوق من احدى البقالات في
بلده حواره وعند خروجهم من البقاله هذا
سياره عشرات المستوطنين
بالحجاره
والبنطات حتى مو زجاج السياره
ما ادى الى اصابه جميع من في السياره
الزجاج المتناثر عشرات المستوطنين اقاموا
حفلات
راقصه او حلقات راقصه على الشارع الرئيسي
وقاموا برشق المركبات الماره
بالحجاره على اثرها كان هناك نداء من
مساجد القريه
بخروج الشبان للتصدي لهجوم المستوطنين
ورقصاتهم في الشارع الرئيسي ما ادى الى
اندلاع مواجهات مع الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي
كان يتواجد
بكثافه الشارع الرئيسي في مدينه
حصل في الاعتداءات السابقه والاعتداء
الكبير بالاحرى على حواره انه الجيش
الاسرائيلي كان موجودا ولكنه بقي متفرجا
على اعتداءات المستوطنين
الذين
حضروا للدفاع عن المحله التجاريه وعن
مركبات في الشارع الرئيسي اطلق قنابل
الغاز والرصاص المطاطي باتجاههم نعم طيب
الحصيله حتى الان نتحدث اذا عن سته جرحى
سته اصابات خمسه برذاذ بشظايا الزجاج
المتنافر واصابه حجر بالراس ولدت ميدانيا
من قبل الهلال الاحمر
الوضع الان هل هذا ام ما يزال متوترا خالد
يعني طالما يتواجد على المستوطنون في
الشارع الرئيسي فهذا دائما يبعث الى
التوتر في المنطقه حتى خروج المستوطنين او
حتى اتخاذ قرار على المستوى السياسي او
العسكري الاسرائيلي المستوطنين من الشارع
الرئيسي الاجواء يوميا هي متوتره في حوار
هناك حذر شديد ويقظه من تكرار الهجمات على
المنازل واحراقها كما تم الاسبوع الماضي
في الشارع الرئيسي خالد هنا سؤال هل هناك
قرار سياسي اسرائيلي بتحريك المستوطنين
هناك بالتزامن طبعا مع الضجه التي اثرها
تصريح وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
الذي دعا الى محو حواره واثاره استهجانا
عربيا ودوليا كبيرين حتى من الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هل هذا مرتبط بقرار
سياسي كذلك في اسرائيل ام لا
يعني هناك تشجيع من معظم اعضاء الكنيست
ومن عدد لا باس به من اعضاء الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
لاعمال المستوطنين في ارواس مودريتش
يشجعون هذه الاعمال وغالبا ما يحضرون
هكذا مناسبات في
القرى العربيه والفلسطينيه ويدعون الى
التصعيد ويدعون الى تكريس الاستيطان في
هذه المناطق لا قرار في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ولكن هناك تشجيع من اعضاء في
الحكومه وتشجيع من اعضاء في الكنيست
الاسرائيلي
هكذا تطرف
استيطاني في الاراضي الفلسطيني خالد
القاسم مباشره من رام الله
[موسيقى]
بعد اجتماعاتنا من مسؤوليه اعلان قرارنا
كمال كلتش دار اوغلو هو مرشحنا الرئاسي
بصفتنا رؤساء الاحزاب السياسيه التي يتالف
منها التحالف الوطني فقد اتفقنا على خارطه
طريق للانتقال الى النظام البرلماني
وقد تنعكس مواقف المعارضه المتارجحه على
حظوظها في الانتخابات المقبله حيث بدات
قاسمه وهو ما قد يؤثر سلبا على صورتها
امام الناخبين لهذا الخصوص ذكرت صحيفه
الامريكيه ان الخلافات الداخليه للمعارضه
التركيه هاديه مجانيه منحت لاردوغان واقلت
الصحيفه ان مساعي المعارضه في ازاحه
الرئيس التركي انتكست بسبب فوضى الخلافات
الداخليه هذا ولم يضيع اردوغان الفرصه
لمهاجمه المعارضه بسبب خلافاتها الداخليه
حيث قال ان همنا هو انقاذ الارواح انهم اي
المعارضه فمصالحهم ومنافعهم بل حتى وذهب
لتحميلها المسؤوليه عن انهيار المباني في
الزلزال
الاحزاب المعارضه وزعيمها زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري السيد كمال كليتجار اوغلو يقومون
بتحريض الشعب للوقوف ضدنا ووضعوا عراقيل
امام عجله النمو والتحول المدني في الماضي
والان يكررون نفس توجهاتهم
اذا الظروف خدمت الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
ساعي لفتره الرئاسيه جديده فرغم ان كارثه
الزلزال سببت صدوعا كبيره في علاقته مع
الشارع الا ان زلزالا اخر ضرب صفوف
المعارضه وادى لصدع كبير في مائده الاحزاب
الست المعارضات ورغم اعلان التحالف اليوم
الا ان الخلافه لا يزال كبيرا المزيد مع
زميل روان حمزه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان على ابواب
انتخابات مرتقبه في حال فوزه فيها قد
يتمدد حكمه المستمر منذ عشرين عاما لكن
هناك ملفات بمثابه حجر عثره خاصه اقتصاديا
ابرزها ارتفاع التضخم لمستوى هو الاعلى
منذ 25 عاما حيث بلغ اكثر من 85% خلال
اكتوبر الماضي حاول الرئيس التركي الدفع
باجراءات تحفيزيه غير مسبوقه للخروج من
الازمه تتضمن دعم الطاقه ومضاعفه الحد
الادنى للاجور وزياده المعاشات التقاعديه
ومنح فرص لتقاعد اكثر من مليوني شخص
الا ان الزلزال شكل له تحديا اخر المعارضه
وبعض الاتراك يحملون حكومته مسؤوليه حجم
الكارثه بين استجابه بطيئه وملفات فساد
ففي السنوات العشرين الماضيه منحت السلطات
تسعه قرارات عفوا كان اخرها في عام 2018
لمبان تعتبر غير قانونيه بينما يرغب
الكثيرون في معرفه اين ذهبت اكثر من 38
مليار دولار تحصلت عليها الحكومه عبر
ضريبه الزلزال التي بدات تطبيقها في اعقاب
زلزال عام
1999 لكن التقديرات تشير الى ان خسائر
تركيا سترتفع بعد الزلزال فتكلفه اعاده
الاعمار ستكون باهظه الثمن وثقيله على
الاقتصاد التركي قد تصل الى 100 مليار
دولار
المعارضه التركيه كانت تراهن بثقل كارثه
زلزال على حكومه اردوغان وتنبات بان تكون
القشه التي تكلفه خساره الانتخابات لكن
استطلاعات الراي تعكس حظوظ اردوغان وتشير
لفوزه بنسبه 49.8
اذا معنى الامن من اسطنبول زيدان زنكلو
زيدان اذا بعد اعتراض زعيمه الحزب الجيد
الاكشينار على اختيار كما جدار اوغلو
اخيرا تم التوافق بين المعارضه التركيه
على هذا المقترح ولكن وفق اي اليه على
ماذا بني هذا الاتفاق بين الاحزاب
المعارضه السته
نعم صهيب نستطيع القول على مبدا المحاصصه
والمشاركه في اتخاذ القرار هذه هي الاليه
التي اسمتها المعارضه خارطه الطريق واسمح
لي بالاستعانه بهذا الدفتر للحديث عن
النقاط الرئيسيه في خريطه طريق طبعا
خاطب طريق تتضمن 12 بندا البند الاول يركز
على ان موضوع التشاور والتوافق فصل
السلطات ضمن النظام البرلماني هو
السيناريو الذي ستنتهجه المعارضه اذا فازت
في الانتخابات
ايضا خارطه الطريق تقول سيتم الانتهاء من
التعديلات الدستوريه الخاصه بالانتقال الى
النظام البرلماني في اقرب وقت يتم تحديد
عدد الوزارات في الحكومه بحسب عدد النواب
المنتخبين من كل من كل حزب على ان يمثل كل
كل حزب بحقيبه وزاريه واحده على الاقل يتم
تعيين واقاله الوزراء من قبل الرئيس بعد
الاتفاق مع رئيس الحزب الذي ينتمي ايضا
توزيع وتحديد الصلاحيات على مجلس الوزراء
اثناء النظام الرئاسي يقوم بموجب مرسوم
رئاسي بعد التشاور اعلان حالات الطوارئ
وتجديد الانتخابات او سياسات الامن القومي
والقرارات الرئاسيه والوراسين يقوم
بالتشاور مع قاده الاحزاب اي ان الرئيس
سيكون مضطرا الى العوده الى الطاوله
السداسيه عند اتخاذه القرارات الهامه او
حتى القرارات التي تتعلق باصدار المراسيم
والموضوع الامن القومي وموضوع الانتخابات
صهيب نعم طيب زيدان لماذا هذا الاصرار على
كمال كريستار اوغلو رغم ان استطلاعات
الراي ربما تعطي حظوظا اكثر لرئي بلديه
انقره واسطنبول منصور يواش واكرم امام
اوغلو
بامكانهما الفوز على رجب طيب اردوغان حسب
استطلاعات الراي فلماذا الاصرار على
هو من اصر على الترشح صهيب يعني الى ما
قبل اشهر قليله كان اكرم امام اوغلو
ومنصور اواش يتحفظان على اعلان رفضهما
الترشح للانتخابات لكن مع الازمه الاخيره
التي عصفت بالطاوله السداسيه كان هناك
بيانات واضحه من هذين الرئيسيين رؤساء
البلديات بعدم رغبته رغبتهما بالترشح كمال
كالجدار اوغلو هو الذي لم يرغب بترشيح
من سوريا واش او امام اوغلو لهذه
الانتخابات هو يعتقد انها هذه الفرصه هي
فرصه مثاليه كي يتقدم للانتخابات وينافس
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان وبحكم انه
اكبر احزاب المعارضه وله الثقل الاكبر على
الطاوله السداسيه استطاع اقناع الجميع حتى
يوم امس
عجاله لو سمحت على ذكر الرئيس اردوغان نعم
هو بدا بمهاجمه المعارضه التركيه بعد كيف
قرئ
هل هو يخشى من منافس قوي في الانتخابات في
مايو ايار المقبل ام لا هو مرتاح لوضعه
اعتقد ان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
كان اكثر السعداء بما شهدته الايام
الماضيه والساعات الماضيه من خلاف
المعارضه حتى الان استطلاعات الراي ما
زالت تعطيه افضليه على كلجدار اوغلو
بافضليه مريحه على جدار اوغلو في
الانتخابات القادمه لكن اردوغان من خلال
تصريحاته اليوم اراد ان يذهب بالمسؤوليه
عن انهيار بعض المباني وتحديدا في نقاط
معينه ويقصد مدينه ولايه هاتاي للمعارضه
التي رفضت مشاريع الحكومه خلال السنوات
الماضيه مشاريع التحول الحضري وخصوصا في
ولايه هاتاي و في اسطنبول وفي عدد من
الولايات الاخرى
زيدان زنكلو مباشره من اسطنبول
[موسيقى]
بعد ان كان الجيش الاوكراني على بعد خطوه
من التخلي عن مواقعه في باخمت تعلن
اوكرانيا اليوم انها باقيه في المدينه حتى
النهايه الجيش الاوكراني اعلن عزمه تعزيز
مواقعه في باكموت حيث تحتدم المعارك ويؤكد
قائد الاركان تاييده لمواصله العمليه
الدفاعيه وذلك خلال اجتماع مع الرئيس بلود
ايضا اعلن انه بحث ملف توزيع الاسلحه
والمعدات بحسب العمليات على الجبهات ولكن
معهد دراسات الحرب الامريكيه اكد ان
تقييماته تشير الى ان اوكرانيا تنفذ
انسحابا تكتيكيا وان لم تعلن عنه هذه
الانباء تتقاطع مع تاكيد قائد قوه فاجنر
الذي الذي تهاجم المدينه تاكيده انه يسيطر
على نحو 40% منها وانه يطوقها من ثلاث
جهات
وفي توتر جديد بين قوات فاغنر والجيش
الروسي اتهم يافدين بريجوجن قائد فاجنر
الجيش الروسي بمنع ممثل قواته من دخول مقر
القوات الروسيه المسؤول عن اداره العمليات
العسكريه في اوكرانيا لافتا الى ان
الكرملين لم يزود قواته بالذخائر والاسلحه
حتى اللحظه
خلف هذه الجبهه يتجدد توتر بين الجيش
الروسي وقوات فاغنر التي تطوق مدينه
باخموت الاوكرانيه بعد اسابيع من تقاذف
الاتهامات التي وصلت حد شتائم والتخوين في
جديد توتر بين الجانبين يقولوا زعيم فاجنر
ايفغيني بريكوجين ان الجيش الروسي منع
ممثله من الدخول الى مقر العمليات الخاصه
الروسيه الذي يدير العمليات العسكريه في
اوكرانيا
اكد الغاء تصريح ممثله ومنعه من الوصول
الى مقر العمليات مجددا حاجه قوته الماسه
لذخيره وان الخطوط الاماميه في بخموت
مهدده بالانهيار وفي حال انسحاب فاغنر
سيتاثر الجميع
فيما يشبه التسابق بين الكريملين وفاجنر
لحصد ثمار الانتصار المحتمل في باخموت
مؤخرا على ظهور مرارا حتى وصل الامر الى
المطالبه بتعيينه وزير للدفاع عبر منصات
غير رسميه مواليه له
قبل بزيارتين لوزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو الى الجبهات احداها الى ماريوبول
والثانيه الى مركز قياده على الجبهه في
دونيتسك
اذا سحبت شركه فاجنر من باخموت فان الجبهه
ستنهار باكملها المقاتلون يسالونني لماذا
التاخير في امدادات الذخيره التي تعهدت
بها وزاره الدفاع الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في
موسكو وايضا لماذا لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد
عناصر جدد
كان وعد بتسليمه اسلحه منذ 23 من فبراير
الفائته لم يتسلم شيئا حتى اللحظه تاخير
فسره باحد الامرين
برقراطيه او خيانه
معنا الان من كييف مراسلنا حذيفه عادل
حذيفه اهلا بك منذ حوالي اسبوع والشائعات
تسري بان الجيش الاوكراني سينسحب من بخمت
ويسلمها للروس تحت وقع ضراوه المعارك هناك
ما الذي تغير اليوم حتى اعلن الجيش الروسي
ان الجنون الجيش الاوكراني عفوا ان الجنود
لا يغادر مواقعهم في ضغط
نعم تحياتي لصهيب يعني والجيش الاوكراني
كل يوم منذ اسبوع يؤكد انه باقي في مدينه
باقمت بشكل مستمر ولكن اليوم طبعا بعد
الانباء التي رشحت والتي كان مصدرها صحيفه
فيلدل الالمانيه التي تحدثت عن خلاف بين
الرئيس فلادي مرسيليسكي والقائد العام
للقوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه فاليري زالوجني
حول الوضع في باكموت وتقول طبعا الصحيفه
ان بحسب مصادر عسكريه وسياسيه مطلعه كما
قالت ان
الفاليري الزالوجني يعني غاضب جدا من
الوضع في باخوه انه نصح بالانسحاب من هذه
المدينه منذ عده اسابيع الامر الذي لم يتم
الاستجابه له ولكن طبعا
لم تعلق الرئاسه الاوكرانيه على هذه
الانباء ولكنها نشرت على الموقع الرسمي
لمكتب الرئيس
زيليسكي ان القرار الذي تم اتخاذه بعد
اجتماع ضمه قاده
الق القائد العام للقوات المسلحه والقائد
الاعلى
الرئيسى وقائد القوات البريه علي
وكذلك الامين العام لمجلس الامن والدفاع
الاوكراني دانيلا تم الاتخاذ القرار
بالبقاء في باخموت وايضا تعزيز الدفاعات
هناك في تلك المنطقه قال ان الاجتماع
استمر لساعه ونصف الوضع في باقود بتفصيل
دقيق جدا وتم اتخاذ القرار بالاجماع
القوات الاوكرانيه باقيه في باقي عنها
وسوف يتم تعزيز الجبهه في طبعا الوضع
محتدم جدا صهيب في باخد من الجهات الثلاث
وحتى الجهه الوحيده التي كان يعني من
السهل ادخال الامدادات اصبح الان من الصعب
ومن شيء هنالك تعقيد في عمليه ادخال
الامداد نعم
الشائعات والخلافات يعني بين العسكريين
ليست في المعسكر الاوكراني فقط بل هي ايضا
في الجانب الروسي كيف ينظر اوكرانيا كذلك
للانتقاد الجديد رئيس مجموعه فاجنر
حول عدم اعطائه الذخيره من الجيش الروسي
وعدم السماح لممثله بدخول الاجتماع القوات
الروسيه
[تصفيق]
في الحقيقه الاستخبارات العسكريه
الاوكرانيه يعني اتى بيانها اليوم يؤكد ما
قاله حول
نقصد ذخيره للقوات الروسيه في جبهه تحديدا
فبيان الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
يقول ان هنالك نقص حاد في الذخيره وفي
الايام القادمه سوف يكون هنالك نقص اكثر
واكثر لذلك تعوض القوات الروسيه
بالقذائف المدفعيه وتقوم بقصف كل شيء
وبدون يعني وجهات معينه او تحديد اهداف
معينه هي تقوم بهدم المدينه باكملها وتضرب
بالضربات المدفعيه في جميع انحاء المدينه
هذا طبعا بيان الاستخبارات العسكريه وايضا
كان هنالك بيان من بعض القاده الميدانيين
في باقي عن ان القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
اليوم استطعت ان تصب عده هجمات بل انها
استطاعت ان تستولي على عده مواقع داخل باق
متوفي ضواحي باخ يعني هنالك اشارات الى ان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تستطيع
تستعيد السيطره وزمام المبادره في تلك
الجبهه مع العلم انها تدافع حتى اللحظه
الرفع عادل مباشره من كيف
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه خامنائي يخالف
رئيسي ويقر بتصميم الفتيات متهما جناتا لم
يسمهم بارتكاب هذه الجريمه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه ونعود
الان الى الاخبار التي بدانا بها اخبار
الساعه لهذه الليله من الضفه الغربيه حيث
روى مواطن فلسطيني حادثه الاعتداء عليه
وعائلته قرب بلده حواره من قبل مستوطنين
اسرائيليين وتعرضهم لاصابات
على السياره
هذا واظهرت لقطته فيديو تلقي افراد عائله
فلسطينيه العلاج الطبي في احدى المستشفيات
بعد تعرضهم لاعتداء من قبل مستوطن
اسرائيلي في حواره دائما
[موسيقى]
ونذهب الى ايران قضيه تسميم الفتيات تخلق
ضجه واسعه وتجبر كبار المسؤولين في البلاد
على محاوله تهدئه الاوضاع المسؤولون
الايرانيون اقروا بوجود الازمه في
الاسابيع الاخيره لكنهم لم يقدموا اي
تفاصيل حول الجهه التي قد تكون وراء هذه
الحوادث او المواد الكيماويه المستخدمه او
وجدت لكن الموضوع ظل يكبر مثل كره الثلج
المتارجحه ما تطلب تعقيبا مباشرا من
المرشد الاعلى علي خامنائي الاخير خرج
للمره الاولى للحديث عن هذه القضيه لكنه
لم يحمل اي جهه المسؤوليه عن هذه الحالات
واكتفى بتوعد المتورطين في حال ادانتهم
باشد العقوبات
قضيه تسميم طالبات المدارس قضيه مهمه اذا
تورط بعض الاشخاص في هذه القضيه فهذه
جريمه كبيره وعلى السلطات تتبع مرتكبيها
بجديه ومعرفه اسبابها هذه جريمه لا تختفر
يجب معاقبه مرتكبي هذه الجريمه بقسوه ولن
يكون هناك عفوا
الوحيده الصادره عن مسؤول الرفيع المستوى
في النظام الايراني بخصوص هذا الموضوع فقد
تحدث كذلك رئيس القضاء الايراني محسن
ايجابي بدوره عن هذه الحالات قائلا ان من
يسمم الطالبات هم فاسدون في الارض ولم
يختلف خطابه عن خطاب خامنائي حيث توعد اي
شخص متورط بطريقه ما في تسميم الطالبات
بالعقاب الشديد مضيفا انه لن يتساهل في
الموضوع
والاكيد ان النظام الايرانيه لم ينكر هذه
المره هذه القضيه لكنه تجاهل في نفس الوقت
الاتهامات الموجهه اليه من العديد من
الناشطين بتدبيرها فالسلطات الايرانيه
اعترفت بوجود شبهه استهداف التلميذات حيث
قال وزير الداخليه الايراني احمد وحيد ان
المحققين عثروا على عينات مشبوهه اثناء
كشفهم ملابسات حوادث التسمم دون ان يخوض
في تفاصيل لكن الداخليه الايرانيه ناقضت
نفسها مجددا وقالت ان النتائج الاوليه
للتحقيقات في قضيه التسمم بالمدارس لم
تكشف عن وجود اي مواد صعبه وان معظم
الطلاب المصابين تعرضوا فقط للذعر
من جهته وصف البيت الابيض احتمال تعرض
الفتيات في ايران للتسميم لمجرد مطالبتهن
بالتعليم بالامر المخزي كما اشار الى ان
تسميم الفتيات في المدارس الايرانيه يدل
على انعدام الضمير مؤكدا في بيانه الى ان
هذا النوع من الهجمات غير مقبوله
هذا وانتشرت صور لاحتجاجات نساء ايرانيات
امام مبنى وزاره التعليم في العاصمه طهران
وذلك على خلفيه ما وصف بالهجمات الكيماويه
على مدارس الفتيات
[موسيقى]
وفيما له صله بايران ايضا ابلغ المدير
العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه رفع
القروسي مجلس المحافظين انه توصل الاتفاق
على تعاون ملموس مع ايران في ملف المواقع
السريه التي تحقق فيها الوكالات الدوليه
منذ سنوات التفاصيل مع رغده به
عاد امين عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رفائيل جروسلي من طهران متفائلا
بتعاون بناء مع ايران رغم التناقض في
تفسيره للاتفاق الذي توصل اليه هناك مع
التفسير الايراني ولكن نبره غروسيا
المتفائله يبدو انها كافيه هذه المره
لتجنيب ايران اي قرار جديد ضدها داخل مجلس
المحافظين وتحدث جروسي في مؤتمر صحفي في
فيينا عن الاتفاق مع المسؤولين الايرانيين
على تعاون في تحقيق الوكاله حول المواقع
النوويه السريه وحول تفسير العثور على اثر
يورانيوم مخصب في منشاه فوردو بنسبه
84%
كنا ندور في حلقه مفرغه والان انطباع بان
هناك فرصه للابتعاد عن هذه الحلقه ونرى
حقا تقدما في هذه النقاط وخاصه في منشاه
فورد التي ستخضع لمراقبه المفتشين كل
يومين
ومع ذلك ما ازال الكثير من الالتزامات
التي حصل عليها غراسي مجرد كلامنا لا
يختلف عن السابق
هناك فرصه جيده ولكن لا يمكنني ان اضمن
الناس يقولون هي وعود وهي ليست وعودا
لدينا بعض الاتفاقات المحسوسه وفي الوقت
نفسه يجب ان استمر بالقيام بعمل
وبالمحاوله
ورغم كلامي غروستي
لاخذ اجوبه من ايران فهو قال بانه سيطلع
المجلس على نتائج المحدثات في ايران او
غيابها قد تكون الدول الغربيه اعطت ايران
فرصه جديده للتعاون مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه بعد ان ابلغ جروستي مجلس
المحافظين بان الوعود هذه المره مختلفه
ولكن اي شعور بالمواطنه من طرف ايران قد
تلمسه الدول الغربيه سيدفعها للتصعيد
مجددا في الاجتماع المقبل لمجلس المحافظين
او حتى اقرب من خلال الدعوه للاجتماع طارق
اذا لزمل امر راغده بهنام العربيه فينا
[موسيقى]
قبل نحو عام كان رئيسا لوزراء باكستان
والان اصبح رجلا مطاردا انه عمران خان بعد
ان حضرت الشرطه الباكستانيه امس من عدم
متولي عمران خان لتحقيق في قضيه فساد
تلاحقه اليوم هيئه حكوميه اخرى حيث قررت
هيئه تنظيم وسائل الاعلام الالكترونيه
الباكستانيه
وذلك في اعقاب خطاب القاه انتقد فيه حكومه
شهباز شريف والجيش القرار تضمن حظر كل
الخطب المسجله والمباشره لعمران خان وذلك
بسبب ما وصفته الهيئه بالدعاءات خان التي
لا اساس لها بحق السلطات ومؤسسات الدوله
عمران خان كان اعلن في خطابنا امس رفضه
المثوله امام محكمه باكستانيه لتحقيق في
قضيه فساد مؤكدا ان مثوله قد يمثل خطرا
على حياته
دالتون لا يوجد امن في المحاكم انهم
يعلمون اني تلقيت تهديدا لحياتي يستدعونني
في قضايا صغيره للغايه من محكمه الى اخرى
[موسيقى]
من باكستان نذهب الى افغانستان الجامعات
اعادت فتحا ابوابها هناك في افغانستان بعد
عطله شتويه طويله لكن دخولها هذه المره
كان مسموحا للشبان فقط وضع جديد فرضه قرار
حركه طالبان والذي يقضي بمنع الشابات من
دخول الجامعات وكان القرار قد اتخذ تحديدا
في نهايه شهر ديسمبر الماضي حيث اعلن وزير
التعليم العالي في طالبان حضره ارتياد
النساء للجامعات مبررا قراره بعدم التزام
الطالبات بالتعليمات المتعلقه بارتداء
الحجاب قرروا منع الفتيات من ارتياد
الجامعات اذا بات ساريه المفعول في
الجامعه الافغانيه قرار عبثا بمصير الالاف
من الطالبات الافنيات اللواتي خضنا
امتحانات الدخول الى الجامعات قبل اقل من
ثلاثه اشهر ليجدن انفسهن الان غير قادرات
على متابعه دراساتهن الجامعيه وتواجه
النساء في افغانستان حركتها منع وحظر من
مختلف مناح الحياه حيث استبعد غالبيه
الوظائف العامه كما تم منعهن من ارتياد
المنتزهات والحدائق وصلاه الرياضه
والمسابح العامه
والى ذلك لم تتوقف المنظمات الدوليه عن
التمديد بقرارات طالبان المنتهكه لحقوق
المراه وفي جديد هذه التمديدات ناشدت
منظمه العقل الدوليه الامم المتحده
بالتصدي للانتهاكات المستمره لحركه طالبان
في افغانستان قالت منظمه العفو الدوليه ان
طالبان استهدفت ايضا نشطاء مدافعين عن
حقوق المراه واكاديميين ونشطاء حقوقيين في
الاشهر الماضيه واحتجزتهم بشكل غير قانوني
ودعت المنظمه مجلس حقوق الانسان التابع
للامم المتحده الى انشاء اليه تحقيق
مستقله في افغانستان في اقرب
اما الامم المتحده ففي تقرير لها حول
اوضاع النساء في البلاد قال المقرر الخاص
بالامم المتحده المعنيه بحقوق الانسان في
افغانستان
قال ان سياسه طالبان المقصوده والمحسوبه
هي التنصل من حقوق الانسان للنساء
والفتيات ومحوهن من الحياه العامه وانه لا
يمكن لبلد ان يعمل في الوقت الذي يسجن نصف
سكانه البالغين في المنازل مؤكدا في
تقريره على ان دور الموظفات الافغانيات
حاسم في تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في
افغانستان
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه وزير الدفاع
تايوان ينظر بعين الريبه للانفاق العسكري
الصيني ويقول ان تستعد لاستخدام القوه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخبار الساعه نذكر
بالاخبار العاجله التي وردت قبل الفاصل
بقليل وكاله الانباء السعوديه تؤكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي بحث مع ناظره البريطانيه
المستجدات على الساعتين الاقليميه
والدوليه وكاله الانباء السعوديه او ردت
كذلك ان وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان بحث مع نظيره البريطاني
للازمه الاوكرانيه للتذكير فقط كان وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الامير فرحان قد زار
اوكرانيا نهايه فبراير الماضي والتقى
خلالها الرئيس الاوكراني
في اوكرانيا واعلنت خلالها السعوديه تقديم
مساعدات الى اوكرانيا بقيمه 410 ملايين
دولار نظمت كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات
المتحده مناورات جويه المشتركه فوق البحر
الاصفر وشملت المناورات استعرض قاذفه
امريكيه قادره على حمل اسلحه نوويه فضلا
عن طائره مقاتله تابعه لسلاح الجو الكوري
الجنوبي وكان البلدان قد اجريا مناورات
مماثله نهايه الاسبوع الماضي ما اثر حفيظه
كوريا الشماليه التي هددت بات اجراءات
قويه وغير مسبوقه مستقبلا ضد مثل هذه
المناورات
[موسيقى]
وفي نفس المنطقه المتوتره يرتفع التوتر
حول جزيره تايوان الصين زياده انفاقها
العسكري صب الزيت على النار واثار حفيظه
تايوان تعليقا للموضوع تحدث وزير الدفاع
التايواني
داخل البرلمان التايوانيه عما وصفه بتزايد
التهديد الصيني وشدد الوزير التايواني على
ضروره التاهب وانتقاد الاستعدادات اللازمه
تحسبا لاقتراب القوات الصينيه من الدفاعات
التايوانيه
وتعرف العلاقات بين الجانبين توترا
متصاعدا في الفتره الاخيره حيث كانت حكومه
تايوان دعت الصين الى احترام حريه الشعب
التايواني في تقرير مستقبله هذه الدعوه
جاءت ردا على تصريحات رئيس وزراء الصين
ليكي تشينغ التي دعا فيها الى التوحيد
السلمي للصين ومعارضه استقلال التايوان
ولا شك ان التايوان تراهن على دعم
الولايات المتحده في حال نشوب اي صراع مع
الصين وفي ذات السياق اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه ان واشنطن قد صادقت على بيع
اسلحه بقيمه تتجاوز 600 مليون دولار
للتايوان من بينها مقاتلات اف 16
هذا هو قناه مصادر الدبلوماسيه امريكيه ان
الرئيس مجلس النواب الامريكيه كبر مكار في
يعتزمون لقاء رئيس التايوان في الولايات
المتحده خلال الاسابيع المقبله وبحسب
المصادف حينما كارثه يخططوا للقاء الرئيسه
في كاليفورنيا اثناء مخططها لزياره امريكا
فكانت زياره لرئيسه مجلس النواب الامريكي
تطالب بضم تايوان
مشاهدينا نعود الى موضوع افغانستان وبدء
سريان تنفيذ قرار حركه طالبان عن الفتيات
من الدخول الى الجامعات حول الموضوع معنا
من كابول لزينب حكيمي الاستاذه الجامعيه
والناشطه في حقوق المراه استاذه زينب شكرا
لك على قبول دعوه العربيه هذا
المساء اليوم فتحت الجامعات ابوابها ولكن
بدون طالبات ما كان شعورك
[موسيقى]
تاثرنا كثيرا منذ اول يوم بقرارات مثل هذه
واليوم بدا يعني العام الدراسي الجديد في
افغانستان بغياب بنات بنات البلد من صفوف
الدراسيه وهذا يعني خبر مؤلم ومؤسف جدا
بالنسبه لنا
يعني كنساء
وكمانات داخل افغانستان هو هذا الامر يدل
على ان قول طالبان
بكون يعني حذر مؤقت لم يكن لم يكنوا يعني
صادقين في هذا القول وايضا قولهم بان هم
يعملون على ازاله الموانئ ايضا لم يكونوا
صادقين في هذا القول والوعد ونحن نحن نحن
يعني
مؤسفين جدا على هذا الخبر نعم هناك شهادات
لطالبات نجحنا في اجتياز قبول الدخول الى
الجامعات في افغانستان ولكن حرمنا بهذا من
اكمال مصاريهم التعليميه وهذا يعني يحبط
احلام الكثير من الفتيات في افغانستان كيف
ترين تاثير القرار منع الفتيات من
الالتحاق بالجامعات في افغانستان كيف ترين
تاثيره على مستقبل البلد على مستقبل
المجتمع الافغاني ككل
طبعا التاثير يعني اكبر مما ربما يعني
يظهر ربما يظهر يعني في الظاهر التاثير
اكبر من منه يعني نحن سنؤثر بهذا القرار
ليس فقط في جيلنا الحاضر بس في اجيالنا
يعني مقبله ايضا لان هؤلاء نعم نعم
الاجيال القادمه لان يعني هؤلاء البنات هم
امهات المستقبل يعني
وطبعا يعني الحين نحن نرى بان عاده كثير
من من الطالبات
اصبنا يعني بامراض نفسيه بضغوطات نفسيه
ويعني
ونرى هناك عدد كبير من العائلات يعني
يحاولن الخروج من البلد يعني حتى حتى ان
كان من طرق غير قانونيه يعني خارج البلد
حتى يبحثوا عن مكان يمكن لبناتهم الدراسه
خارج البلد فهذا يعني تاثير كبير جدا
وايضا
في الجامعات اثار غضب بالمجتمع الدولي
وادانت من دول بما فيها الدول المسلمه
كذلك ادانت هذا القرار هل تتوقعين ان تغير
طالبان شيئا في قرارها
اول شيء نامل فيه يعني كشعب اول شيء مال
فيه هناك عدد من قاده لبان هناك عدد من
شخصيات من رموز طالبان يخالفون هذا القرار
وان كانوا لم يصرحوا بهذا المخالفه فنحن
نامل اولا في هؤلاء الشخصيات ان يقدموا
يعني ان يطلعوا للامام ويصرح مخالفتهم
ويقف جنب الشعب حتى يعني
يعني اذا لا يكون لهؤلاء اثر في قادتهم
لمن يكون اذن لكن طبعا الضغوط الدوليه
ايضا له اثر ونحن نناشد يعني نناشد العالم
ونطالبهم
باستمرار هذه الضغوط وباي طرق كان يعني
وايضا معه اعتراضات مدنيه من الداخل نحن
يعني نستمر بهذه الاقتراحات فطبعا يكون له
تاثير يعني شكرا جزيلا لك على حضورك معنا
مباشره من كابول زينب حكيمي انت الاستاذ
الجمعيه والنشطه الحقوقيه في مجال حقوق
المراه مشاهدينا شكرا لكم على كرم
المشاهده اخبار الساعه الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]